para muchos ucranianos la vida se
trasladó a un subterráneo hace menos de
un mes era impensable este panorama en
los andenes del metro de la capital
ucraniana tiendas de campaña colchones y
maletas instaladas para refugiar a miles
de personas que huyen de la guerra según
el alcalde de kiev unos 15 mil
ciudadanos en su mayoría mujeres y niños
se han refugiado en estas instalaciones
[Música]
ya llevo 24 días aquí a veces voy a mi
apartamento para darme una ducha y
cocinar algo pero regreso al metro
porque definitivamente es uno de los
lugares más seguros
normal compramos algunas cosas de afuera
el resto lo traen voluntarios sobre todo
agua y comida aquí no nos morimos de
hambre solo que en estas circunstancias
a veces es difícil tener ganas de comer
las sirenas antiaéreas y el sonido de
las explosiones se han vuelto cotidianas
los días pasan y la guerra no da señales
de terminar para las familias con niños
encontrar actividades para pasar el
tiempo es un problema diario net qué
tipo de entretenimiento puede haber aquí
para ellos cuando hay una guerra en el
país la vida es monótona no tenemos nada
que hacer excepto cuidar de nuestros
hijos y tratar de mantener nuestra
higiene personal de la mejor manera
posible animales según la onu de los 44
millones de habitantes de ucrania más de
3 millones han cruzado fronteras en
busca de seguridad y unos 6.5 millones
se desplazaron internamente lejos de los
ataques y bombardeos rusos